[Applaudissements]
parce qu'elle est exemplaire
bram on verra alors ça va peut-être
peut-être yens majeur c'est que pour une
galaxie
vous savez donc ce qu'il vous arrive
c'est ray lane marquez que thébaux
m
et noël sont gens me dit quelque chose
qu'est ce qu'il ya mal le pays
chawaf merci d'être avec nous il est 20
heures 12
[Musique]
ah oui quand même
asap mais quoi pas comme ça non pas
comme ça non non
merci aux téléspectateurs ne nous
rejoindre dans touche pas à mon poste
le magazine de la dark à 20h12
je n'ai pas envie de rire tous ses
angles et ça a fait des progrès ta
gueule
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce soir j'ai envie de marcher marcher
marcher
cherche-t-elle de pins maritimes à
gaston pas bien sûr pardon je viens
d'apprendre une nouvelle
ah ah
musique roots qui m'a glacé le sang et
vous aussi chez vous je vais demander à
tous ceux qui nous regardent aller
chercher leurs amis leurs ennemis leur
concierge leur gardienne leur gardien
leur médecin leur voisin
j'ai envie que tous ceux qui nous
regardent et je demande au public de le
faire se lève et se prennent tous par la
main
c'est quoi ces conneries faites là bas
j'aimerais vous prenez tous les mains ce
qu'on appelle dans le milieu aquatique
les mains au crabe tu voudras pas le
faire avec moi j'aimerais que tout
public et les mains en crabe j'aimerais
que les chroniqueurs et les invite
également ya un mois nasri se prennent
léman au crabe sans que la note d'accor
regarder ça va tout ce soir michel
gentil que je ne verrai plus jamais les
choses de la même manière car ce soir un
séisme s'est abattue sur le paf
ah oui bon je viens vous demanderez
qu'une chose
oui il faut que je vous dirais la
nouvelle ah oui je vous demanderai de
vous taire je vous demanderais
de ne piper mot en résumé mme otis
s'arrête
ah oui quoi oui dans cette phrase il y
avait un indice un double sens
[Musique]
c'est vrai en plus si vous nous
rejoignez à 20h15 la nouvelle vient de
tomber et quoi
fait peur
allez dans ce que ça morde cette fois
c'est quoi l'amour passa pas comme ça
[Musique]
allez je vous le dis quoi et quoi et on
voit aux classes vont ou non mais moi
j'ai peur du chocolat un bon boîtier
mais ces plans du choc ou de moyen
tonnage a fait chaud c'est comme ça et
on va d'accord quand même bon qu'est ce
qu'une mère cet état ce qui met dans cet
état
[Musique]
thierry beccaro arrête motus non
c'est
[Applaudissements]
j'adore j'ai envie de dévorer les boules
ma non mycube france télévisions c'était
monsieur arrêtez c'est
cessé de vivre moi j'aime beaucoup tiré
aussi nous aussi ah non je suis là alors
franchement là dieu et merde c'est dans
ces moments là qu'on a besoin d'un ami
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention pas la boule noire
[Rires]
alors on rigole mais c'est vrai c'est
une nouvelle incroyable écart avec
monsieur s'équipent france télévisions